[Music]
okay put your knee in alignment with
your foot that was some yesterday so you
need that for the internal aspects and
you're not attacking his hands nor his
Center gravity on the Makia
tush okay so that's the
embryonic
right there's no block on makos there's
no block on the kesa
Uchi
again it's not in his Cent it's not in
his Center if you're not in his Center
you can't you can't check his feet and
then he can deviate do you see so you
won't be there for your
ski
good
Brea breathe
breathe the body moves fast the Mind
stays
[Music]
still so let's go back don't block his
ski attack his
head
there you go okay you can't wait
there you're doing an embryonic machia
tush and we're not doing embryonic right
now we're working on the initial
violence of
action
okay you still want to do the makot Tosh
mechanics it's just not the makio to
embryonic
timing so again this light on his hands
okay so what makes it light on his hands
is not your your energy like how fast
you're going of course that would make
his hands hurt more but it's the body
mechanics is not there you're doing a
different body mechanics so when I say
light on his hands what I mean is you
don't have the body mechanics to put
your weight
into the tip of the weapon onto his
hands and into his Center do do you guys
understand that so for
example uh I sure I don't care okay so
if I'm out here
clearly I'm not in the right place it's
not in his hands do you see that or
because I'm out of range say yes it's
too obvious okay but if I'm over here
and I'm uh aing just down on his hands
then it's not in his Center okay or if
I'm I go here and I'm on the side of my
weapon do you see I'm my drop weight
here there's no weight being dropped on
the weapon this is this is the wrong
mechanics even if he lowered his hands
that would be the wrong week and I would
call you on it you don't have you're not
putting a weight in the attack okay
I say this so you understand it's not
really about speed it's just about
proper body mechanics okay and when I'm
telling you put your put your weight on
the end of the joke I don't mean move
move your bad body mechanics faster
that's not what I mean okay so you can
do this slowly and in fact I think you
have to because of the nature of the
time and you don't want to break each
other's hands
okay um me meaning if I can if he can't
do the aemi I have to be able
to take the injury part out of it okay
do do you guys understand is in the same
way if uh I ski and he's going to do
that application timing not the
embryonic timing on the kuchi we go and
if I mess up on my thing he doesn't
crack me in the head do do you
understand okay would be no difference
for makou okay so again to review what
we're trying to do is work on the
constant violent of
action to do that I don't use the
embryonic timings I don't have blocks
our Joe's don't really touch like we're
not hitting each other's sticks we're
always attacking the other
person don't ever go backwards and
minimize how much lateral deviation you
you use but at the same time don't move
into where he wants to now kick me
especially if I have taken his Joe out
of the fight okay so where that tends to
happen is as you're trying to do your
violence of action you'll over penetrate
here you see and you come like this
you're going to take his weapon out of
the fight he knows I don't have anything
else so I'm going to go to my empty hand
web that's what he would do okay I want
to be in that sweet spot where he has to
fight with the Joe okay not go to
something else so some of you are over
penetrating some of you are going
backwards some of you going too
laterally some of you have poor body
mechanics on the
Makia okay so I'll show you we can go
slow as we
[Music]
go he doesn't touch my Joe
but he has the same mechanics of the
embryonic timing you see same exact
mechanic same thing goes on the Maia to
I don't I don't go like
this I could have pass through that
movement okay so I'm going
through
there I was late and he didn't crack me
in the
head okay let's try to get in part one
but I don't block on the machia tush
you're not block you cannot there's no
blocking in AO okay so I don't ever want
to go here but that's not going to work
in real
life let's see how slow we can go okay
it'll even slower than that okay so my
angle he's he's going the right timing
but slower so he's mov
W
back is what I'm doing I'm not going
here boom that's the embryonic training
Time
Boom my attack
is on the HS do you see that or maybe
somewhere around here and then you slide
down to the hands okay so try to watch
how I'm doing that my Joe never makes
contact here but it does pass through
here it makes contact there that's the
first Contact so we're
going
different that's different okay all
right try it
again okay so many times in part five of
the Gateway video especially in the
teacher highlights I repeatedly
emphasize that if the strike hits you
it's not the end of the world you keep
moving the target you yield the target
okay it's no different than if he threw
a punch at my face I don't keep it there
he goes you'll see me roll roll my face
okay so my uh Mr Pig my Kad teacher
that's that to him that was angle
deviation let the guy hit you and roll
roll take off that energy because he was
right where he wanted him to be for his
angle attack he's not too far away you
see that uh you see it him boxing all
the time uh and then in the last rep I
showed you that you could actually
adhere on the weapon as it hit the
target okay okay there's some of that
going on in the maku chemi cuz your
hands are going to get hit he did his
job you see that but I keep yielding the
target okay as I keep yielding the
target I start to come off the line of
attack so first yield then off the line
of attack otherwise you you're just
going to get nailed or checked out and
the ski is going to hit you you cannot
continue the form okay so uh he's he's
going to go go slow and smooth Bo let's
not do the
embryonic but slow that I can kind of
talk
[Music]
Bo you see how I yielding with
it
somewhere
around here you can move ever so
slightly ever so slightly so for if
you're afraid don't move it at all cuz
you're going to move too much all I need
to do is the rotating
cross as he's pushing I roll around
there do you see and then I have my
angle
deviation it's going to touch you it's
not going to break you okay so all I'm
doing that that keeps me in the fight
it's not he breaks my hands and now it's
my I countered his attack okay and then
he would continue with the violence of
action and that sets up Hadi hadai ski
is when someone's running at
you let the lion jump on your spear Hadi
ski is not you advancing
okay so we
go
pop is my my
movement remember what he's trying to do
run me over he's not trying to defend
himself get all the timey right all the
M right
boom is where I'm
at slower let
smooth
same
[Applause]
P if I didn't move he's going to scre
me so I do aido ton in one
movement with one
step don't go e me ten con there's no
time his Target is here on the ski
that's what I
[Music]
deviate same way on the Kessa you pass
through the
embryonic right so he's doing it I'm
passing through the embryonic
architecture there it is but I don't use
it same thing on the
machia I pass through the embryonic
architecture but I don't use
it same thing on
hanai start it start
top you're passing through it but if you
wait here he's not going to be there you
want to hit him on
his inertial
advancement pass through it pop and yeah
that's what makes it just po flick and
into skewering the charging line okay
let's try it so the har part the brush
part is a hand attack remember always
attack what is closest to you okay so we
go slow so you can see it he's
[Music]
going it's right there okay it's a a
flick and then get him to skewer himself
which means he has to counter the hand
attack anytime you do a ski anytime you
stick your weapon in this middle space
between us you're always aware that you
could be defanged it's just it goes into
to what you're doing with with weapons
so even if I had my firearm between us I
am constantly aware that the weapon and
the arm holding the weapon could be
attacked so
here I he's going to do his ski his hand
is between us he's ready to counter the
hand being attacked so it's he that
counters it's not me that I miss over
here do you see that because what
happens is if he was violently coming in
I'm not going to get that thing back
there
okay so you have to have good H ey
mechanics this is bad H ey mechanics
it's here and Bo right into the Ste move
okay slow and smooth boom pop there's
the hand there's the
skewer if you follow those mechanics
what you're going to see is that you're
moving behind your weapon the entire
time the weapon is shielding
you so from the beginning the weapon
stop the weapon is shielding me I am on
the other side of the weapon even though
it's not blocking I am on the other side
of the weapon boom other side of the
weapon Okay add that and that counter on
the defang in the snake attemp
go okay stay
there move James please
okay so look get your body this
way and the back leg you're more 50/50
and so this is right so when I when I
come in you see so let's change your
body let's put weight on the
front good put this under your
Center
good ground and use your back
leg
okay there you go okay and that's what
you want to ishido ten con into you
don't want to go in that stance because
he just going to Barrow you over okay
all right thank